[Music]
hey on today's show we talk about hard
hard stuff so please watch out for the
little ears
in the room talk to a mom who's trying
to love her son through his divorce
we talked to a woman who's experienced
the depths of trauma
and is trying to claw her way back stay
tuned
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john deloney's show
the show about your life your challenges
the good stuff the bad stuff your mental
health your relationships your families
your boundaries
your workplace all of it i'm here to
walk alongside you
it's one of the greatest honors of my
life people from all over the planet
call in and say hey man i got nobody to
talk to
or i've tried to get some information
from this person from that person and
i just can you help me out yes
and if i can't we'll we'll make it up as
we go
and hey by the way this is the second
attempt to record this episode we got
into the last episode
and um ben
hill is pinch hitting for james it's
true
ben is more technically proficient than
james by a hundred miles right
100 yeah no question the one key feature
though that we've discovered in
recording i don't know we're up to
almost 150 episodes here one of the
cornerstone
practices of recording a podcast or a
youtube show
is actually hitting the record button
and um
so you can turn all the microphones on
and the music
it sounds all cool everybody back there
like kelly's waving her arm she's like
it's another show
none of that happens by the way she
pretty much
looks like she's reading a phone book
but everybody gets all excited
ben you forgot to hit the record button
man i did i let you down john
let down earth i'll write down everyone
but listen here's what you've done
bravely you owned it i caught it
so here's some some inside baseball
we've done whole episodes where james
didn't hit the record button
and i love talking about him because
he's not here so great and he's going to
edit all this out which is even greater
so fun but ben stepping into pinch hit
says hey hey hey let's just stop
everything i forgot to hit the record
button can we do this again
yes we can yes we can ben
you're a man of integrity i'm glad
you're recording and if you're not thank
you for you don't
even hear this it'll be great but listen
so glad you're
you're on you're taking care of the
podcast and i'm so glad to all the
listeners who are joining us today
whether you're in your car you're by
yourself you're on a hike you're on a
walk you're vacuuming whatever it is
you're doing
so glad you're with us um we're gonna
have a i don't forget a good time we're
gonna have a tough time we're gonna
walk alongside some folks if you want to
be on this show give me a call at
six 1-844-6900 three three two nine one
it's one eight four four six nine three
thirty two ninety one
leave a message kelly will call you back
or go to johndalone.com
ask she might not call you back if she
doesn't wanna have you on the show
or i don't even know what she's doing so
anyway all right let's go to susie
in lubbock texas hey susie what's going
on
hi how are you i'm doing all right how
about you
oh okay hanging in there hanging in
there
is it awesome that you have called into
easily the most professional
classy um clean
podcast radio show on earth it's pretty
awesome i think
it's super awesome it feels like
sometimes we're driving down the street
in like a 1993
chrysler minivan and like
callers just have their thumb out and
we're like dumb and dumb like pick them
up right so come on in susie
right along with us we're so so glad
you're here what's that
mock yeah yeah pick em up
all right susie so what's going on
well i have a bit of a family situation
um i have a 24 year old son
that has been married about a year and a
half and
his wife has left and filed for divorce
i feel like her family is
really fueling it they're definitely
supporting it and i'm struggling to
know where my place is and how involved
i should be how i can help my son how i
can encourage him
and i just i just don't know what i can
do to help
yeah ugh that's powerless and a scary
feeling huh
totally and tell me if i'm wrong and
there's i mean just off top of my head
it feels like there's two main
hurts here three main hurts number one
man that's your little boy and he's
heartbroken and devastated and nobody
likes to see their kid hurt right so
that one's real
right and then there's
yeah yeah it's awful and like what i do
how do i help this
and then there's this other thing which
is
and how do you not turn into
somebody who's whining and complaining
and pointing fingers and blaming
but everybody in your community out
there in
the you know west texas and eastern new
mexico in that community
how's your son doing and now you got you
have to tell the story and there's a
part of you
somewhere down there it's gonna feel
like you screwed something up
yeah like if you had
done x y and z then you would not have a
you're a mom of a divorce kid now and
there's like a thing in your heart about
that
am i right well i
i'm a divorced mom so oh
no okay that's a that is a brick i
struggle with
yeah and also you've been down this road
before
yes oh man
few things set our body response systems
off more than break our hearts
is when new wounds just
peel back what we thought was healed
scars right
man so
here's the sucky part and here is the
honest as i can part um well actually
before i do that before i just start
yik-yaking what does help look like when
you say man how do i help what
what do you imagine do you imagine
coming in what are some things you can
say and do that will hold this
marriage together that will help them
heal
what does help look like for you yes
help to me is getting her to listen to
me
and just say stop it and just her
stopping
[Laughter]
that's what i it her to do is just stop
it you're my favorite person i've talked
to today
that's so you're incredible do you have
that kind of relationship with her
you know i thought that i did i honestly
thought that i did and that's part of
the hurt is that she has decided
that she won't talk to me she does not
want to talk to me and told me
i will not sit down and talk to you so
can i flip that around for a second
yes i bet she can't talk to you
i bet she can't
whether and i say that she could right
she could stand up be strong take the
next step
and all those you know things she could
be a disciplined person a person of
character and integrity and have that
conversation she could
but my guess is her family has drawn a
thick line which is them or us
and my guess is in her 23 or 24 year old
little heart and mind
she doesn't have the words or tools to
stare at somebody who she knows has been
down this road before
y'all probably talked about this about
your divorce about your
y'all probably had those conversations
before man yeah
she's got a wheelbarrow full of monkeys
that she's carrying around
and i don't know that she's got the
ability the tools or the cognitive
capacity character what are you going to
say
i don't know if she can't have that
conversation with you
and that's one of those things that
you're going to carry around with you
until you decide to let that go because
there's a part of you that is
yeah you just said it you're hurt by her
don't give that power to her
you can have your heart broken by her
you can be frustrated by her don't let
her
hurt you because i don't think she's
being intentional i think she's
staring down the barrel of a whole bunch
of stuff right
yes so why is she leaving your son
that's hard
yeah i know it's it's yeah i made it
sound like it's like hey man just put
the broom down i know it's not that easy
right um but if every time you think if
she would just
if you could switch that and catch
yourself and say
i'm heartbroken that she can't
maybe one day she will but i would look
at it as a matter of capacity and
ability
not as a matter of character it might be
character
but that's not going to get anybody
anywhere you know what i mean um
what why is she walking out on your son
well you know they're um young and
um probably
well they they're not mature and um he
will admit
wait wait what hold on yeah 24 year old
married couple's not mature what are you
talking about
with a one-year-old how dare you
susie i got married when i was 24 and i
was
the wisest guy ever now is part of the
problem actually
i knew everything when i was 24 and
young and married
and i didn't have a one-year-old jesus
louise okay so they're immature
like all 24 year olds are and if you're
24 and listening to this
yes you yeah right there through
man caitlyn's running the the video
monitor today and she's like what me
yes katelyn you right oh man okay so 24
one-year-old that's a lot of pressure
what else
um i said i believe her family is
really fueling it because although um
they're young
and and inexperienced um
you know he went out partying
one too many times with the guys not his
finest moment not something he should
have been doing
but i don't believe it's something that
they can't work through
and um so i guess that's where
i'm struggling
no okay there's been no infidelity no no
drug use
uh no abuse just an idiotic 24 year old
being an idiotic 24 year old
yes okay not that it excuses it but i
get what you're saying right
yeah um again i think it's something
that can be
can be fixed and can be worked through
but um
she's insisting that it can't and she's
done
and that breaks my heart because they
have a one-year-old
and it changes all of their lives
forever forever and that little baby's
life forever too
and so i feel like okay i know he's
grown i know she's grown
but because i'm the parent and because
i've been there i feel like
us as parents and as a family we should
be encouraging them
to go to counseling encouraging them to
work it out not to walk away
but so her side of the family's like no
be done with him and walk away and
that's what i'm
that breaks my heart too yeah so
her you can't nothing you can do can
help her side of the family right you
can't can't change the way they talk to
her you can't change their views on
marriage you can't change their views on
your son
right and if they called me they would
probably tell me about some rambunctious
guy that's running the street at night
hanging out with his buddies while his
wife's
home caring for a newborn right they
tell me that that'd be their story right
yeah and it would be true also right so
it's bo it's all
um i'm with you i don't think that's a
reason to cash in on a marriage but i
also don't know how many times she's met
with them if they've gone to
i don't know any that kind of stuff
right and every single couple on the
planet i don't care how well parents
think they know their kids there's
always stuff behind closed doors
always you know that better than anybody
right um
here's the hard part for you you are in
a relationship with this woman for the
rest of your life
she is the mother of your grandchild
right
any ill will you harbor towards her any
poison you put out into the water
or into the air will be drank and
breathed up by your grandkid
and that's how trauma moves through
family gender
generation to generations generations
one because one parent just pops up and
says i'm getting divorced right
that lights the forest fire and then
resentment disdain
anger um ugliness
running people down being pissed off all
the time that's what fuels that fire for
generations
and so what you're gonna have to do in
short order is decide in your soul i'm
not gonna go to war with his
ex-wife i can't control her as much as i
want to
i can love the crap out of my son
and what does that look like that looks
like
man this is a severe severe consequence
but he needs to get his life
in order right he's got a little baby um
he's gonna have to stop running in the
streets and those are some conversations
you can have with him now is he's going
to heal and go what now
because the temptation is going to be to
double down on that that's the only
community he's got left that's the only
connection he's got left right you're
going to have to really be there for him
to walk alongside him there
um so your help if you if the way i see
it your
your help is going to be helping him
heal helping him be a man of character
that's going to contribute to whatever
arrangement some court is going to
decide for their family
making sure that he never
ever talks bad about that woman in front
of his kid because that's just gonna be
running down that kid's mom
and that he's gonna have to grow up real
real fast
when i hear help that's what i hear i
don't know that you can stop this train
that's already left the station
i think you can help this thing stay on
the tracks
and i know that feels so powerless
have you called her her parents
yes how did that go
not well i mean tell me about it they
just said
they support her decision and they're
not going to encourage her
to stay in a relationship where she's
not happy
so that's where they stand okay even
though i pleaded with them
i would never i i love her and i have
only tried to encourage her even through
this whole thing i have reached out to
her to tell her i love her
i'm not going to stop praying i want the
best i never want her to be mistreated
by anyone
ever even if that's your own son um
exactly
um and i wanted them both you know
to get healing um that they could do
this
but her parents told me that they
you know they don't support her staying
with him
what happened with um your divorce give
me a quick synopsis of that
oh gosh my divorce was um
the reason we got divorced or just the
process itself
uh we were married 11 years and it was a
on-again off-again relationship before
we got married um
i just you know we had good years and
bad
a lot of bad years we weren't kind to
one another
in the end and i just could never get on
the same page who ultimately left who
um it was sort of a mutual
but um my husband is the one who
actually filed for divorce
is there anything about what just
happened with your son
that you see in your ex-husband
yes
the unwillingness to to talk about it an
unwillingness
to actually have the hard conversations
make the changes
stick it out even though it's not fun
it's a part of you thinks that at some
level
how old was he when y'all got divorced
held was my son ten
ten so you had a ten ten-year-old little
boy in your house
and whether you thought it or not you
had a mission
i'm gonna raise a different kind of man
right however however misguided or
opportunistic or whatever i'm gonna
raise a different kind of man
one that fill in the blank
i need you to be at peace with your soul
that you didn't fail anything
okay even though you're watching history
repeat itself in real time
susie's sentencing susie to a lifetime
of more punishment
won't keep this marriage together it
won't keep you well and whole it won't
help your relationship with your son and
he needs you right now
i need susie to be really kind and
forgiving to susie
why are you laughing that's hard
i know i know it is way harder to be
kind to myself
than it is to someone else it is it's
way harder
because you know what you think and you
know your attitudes you know your
judgments and you know your whatevers
but i need you to be kind to susie and
when you
treat susie with dignity and respect the
same dignity and respect you would hope
that they'll treat your grandkid or your
son or your
daughter-in-law then you can talk openly
and honestly with your son
about hey what's happened has happened
you can learn one thing you got to
change your life
because your son's got some major
growing up to do
major growing up to do and the hardest
part of any parent
who has adult kids is that you can't
make it make him change you just can't
you love him and encourage him you can
you can
double down on on connecting with him
invite him over for lunch have coffee
with him write him letters make sure
you're texting him all these things
but he's going to decide i'm not going
to go with my buddies anymore i'm going
to get a job and clean my crap
up as far as
his ex-wife it sounds like that ship has
sailed the
i if i'm you i would leave no stone
unturned
what does that mean that means i would
write her a letter that's the only way
you can get to her now
and let her know that you love her you
care about her
and you were really honored to have her
in your family you would love it if she
stayed
you're going to be a great grandmother
to that their baby
you're never going to say something
negative about her put all that in
writing for her
and tell her that you're not going to
give up on your son you're going to
compete
pushing on him and prodding on him and
doing every motherly thing you can to
get him to change his life and turn that
crap around
but instead of telling her what she
needs to be doing right now we all know
that we all know
we all also know that we don't know what
went on behind closed doors
and we know that man at some point she's
going to cut off relationships with
everybody
and you're playing a long game now with
your grandkid
and your grandkids mom and your
grandkids dad
hate that for you susie i know it's
heartbreaking start with being kind to
susie
start with doubling down on loving your
son and sometimes loving it means
ringing his little
neck and reach out and let that mom know
you support her you love her you can be
a great grandma
love to see them back together
[Music]
and by the way somebody out in west
texas says hey what happened
hello i'm not going to talk about it
talk about other things
you don't have to tell any of this story
that you don't want to you're a grown
woman susie you can do what you want to
don't tell the story to anybody oh man
all right let's take a quick break and
we'll be right back on the dr john
dolone show
[Music]
hey what's up i want to take a quick
break to talk about the most important
question i'm asked almost every day
how do i find a counselor if you can't
find a counselor in your area
or you can't afford one i've got a
solution for you
i've partnered with a better help for
customized online therapy
video chat text chat phone counseling
it's a licensed therapist whenever and
wherever
you need them go to betterhelp.com slash
deloney for 10 off your first month it's
cheaper
and it's available all the time this is
for you
your family and for everyone else that's
coming your way take care of your mental
health go to betterhelp.com today
all right and we are back let's go to
liz in charleston
south carolina hey liz what's going on
hi dr john thank you so much for taking
my call
hey thank you for giving me a shout
what's going on
um i was calling to ask
how do i have the conversation
with my
before you go two things talk directly
in the phone
and i can already hear
there's something really close to the
surface are you okay
yeah take a deep deep breath for me
and just hold it
and now let it out
is where you're calling from safe yes
cool i promise to be safe too and i will
only make fun of ben
in the control room that's it you got it
okay all right cool okay so how do you
have the conversation
and that's um keep going
that i am a survivor of sex trafficking
[Music]
um
um
i just
i'm
so are you married and your husband
doesn't know correct
okay um how long have you been married
um a little under a year
how long did y'all date before um
since 2018 summer of 2018. i see all
been together for a while
how old are you yeah um i'm 28.
28 okay you like this guy
yes a lot is he super good looking
yes he is for rick for real are you just
saying that
sometimes you talk to somebody and
you're like hey is that guy good your
husband looking and she's like oh my
gosh yes and you see him
you're like nope no he's not right
and how did you meet him um
we go to the gym together oh gross
you're at the gym just flexing and he
was like doing tricep extensions looking
at you
yeah pretty well hey totally side
conversation i know we're in the middle
of a heavy thing
how how do you
how do how do you how do you meet
somebody at a gym how does that happen
um like how's the who made the first
move
this is one of life's great mysteries to
me
um inadvertently me i um
that's so ridiculous liz i said i wasn't
gonna laugh at you but i lied
what do you mean inadvertently um
i thought he was we were leaving the gym
at the same time
and i thought he was asking me for my
phone number
but he was actually talking to the
person behind me
um that's the most preposterous so you
just walked up to this super hot guy
leaving a gym and you handed him your
number and you're like oh
you just asking for yeah he was actually
talking to the guy behind him because
they were going to work out together
listen liz that may be one of the
greatest moves i've ever heard of
i've heard of crazy moves that's legit
i've never heard of that one
where you just walk up to a stranger and
you're like oh hey um
you were just asking for my number here
it is that's a baller move
and then he clearly was like okay
yeah and then he called you or texted
you or whatever
yeah ladies and gentlemen
that's how the gym date is is born
and that could have gone sideways but it
didn't so now ended up with a marriage
all right okay thank you for solving
life's great mystery i will now give you
free advice on whatever your challenges
are how about that it's a good trade
okay so you're with this guy
let's reverse engineer this you've been
with him for a couple of years
he's awesome he's wonderful you care
about him you love him you married him
you are building a life with him and
you've got this
big deep dark
hidden past right tell me about what
happened in the past
um i was in a
relationship with someone for four years
um that was abusive in
every single way you could think of
and it just like
tiny little things just kept escalating
and escalating and tell me what that
means
tell me what that means um
it it means
like stuff
you i guess the way he like introduced
this to me
was that he was like well i just want to
have a threesome
and of course like being in a
relationship and wanting to
um make your partner happy that's
kind of how that started and then so
slowly your boundaries just got pushed
further
and further in little increments right
yeah and before i knew it he
was he reached out to
an escort service and started pimping me
out
through their service
and ultimately how were you able to
transition
out of that um
i ran away i
i mean like he had told me that the only
way i was ever going to get out
is that if we like essentially both
he was going to like take him kill me
and then take himself out
sure well
and so for for the the person listening
wondering how does this happen i would
and it's easy to think i would just do
this or i would
i would just um what i'll let you know
is there are power dynamics at play in
these situations there
is really challenging
um
really tough psychological um
things that happen physical things that
happen when you're in a highly abusive
and toxic relationship
and you just said it perfectly suddenly
you wake up and one day you've
highly uncomfortable with the next step
but it will keep you safe today
and then you become yeah highly
uncomfortable the next step but
nobody's gonna get hit and
yeah it's easy to say hey i'll just call
so and so but
not if somebody's got your cell phone
right or they're paying for your bill or
so
it's not one of those things that you
just wake up one day and you're flipping
through netflix and someone's like hey i
got an idea it's not how it works right
and so i want everyone listening to this
to understand
the physiological the psychological the
biological
pathway the way this works is not a
simple oh my gosh just
it's not right
and then suddenly yeah you find yourself
underwater and that water comes up
around you and you're chained to the
floor and all of a sudden you're
drowning
right and you ran away tell me about
what that looked like
um i
knew he had to be in
another city about two hours away from
where we were living
um so that i had about
a five to six hour window um
to pack up my dogs and all
anything i could fit in my car and take
with me
um so i i did i dropped
my dogs off at a hotel
and told them what was going on
that i was running away from an abusive
relationship and
i just needed a place to drop my dogs
off while i
tried to get as much of my things out of
my health as i could
and can we pause right there just again
for the listener
if you are have never been trapped in an
abusive or traumatic relationship
often i've seen people who will hold
their dog or their
cat in a way that is a it's like holding
a life raft
right these weren't just your dogs these
were your last
last thread connected to reality
right yeah this is the only safe thing
you've got so
i again i'm trying to i'm trying to play
by play this for the listener
um man you think like just leave your
dogs and run man that's all i got
right yeah and when you're in a fire you
hang on to that teddy bear with all you
got right
so okay so you've dropped your dogs off
you run away
where did you go um
i stayed at the hotel long enough
to get my things i actually broke into a
storage
facility um and
wound up calling the owner once i got a
hold of them because i lived in the
middle of nowhere and they don't just
like
sit at the facilities
and was like hey this is what i'm doing
i'll
pay you when i can um
but i knew if i
left my dogs he would find a way to like
hold hold that over me and of course
know that i'd be protective of them and
threaten to hurt them
and so fast forward
did you end up going to the police did
you end up going to a care shelter
how did you get into a place where you
started dating again you started going
to the gym again
you started like tell me about that
journey yeah
i um i moved back home to my parents
um did you talk to them about all this
uh i talked to them about the abuse but
i've never
actually told them the extent of it um
i don't i don't know like part of me
doesn't want to put that on them
even though like you know they're my
parents and that's what they're there
for
but i i guess it's the same thing with
like
now feeling the need to tell my husband
like i don't want to keep
this like huge secret from him but at
the same time like how do i
dump something that big on him
or anyone i care about because they
first and foremost man i'm so sorry
you've got one beautiful precious life
and somebody stole a big chunk of yours
and i'm sorry
and i know that doesn't make it go away
i know that doesn't make it
better but right now when you're just
sitting there in a pool and don't have
any water in it you just got your face
in your hands i want you to know i'm
sitting there right next to you
sucks i hate that
hate that so
the demon of abuse the reason abuse is
so evil besides the the power dynamics
and the actual
pain that that abuse causes is it
weaponizes the only thing that makes us
whole
that makes us people which is
relationships the only thing that makes
us
able to function our hearts literally
beat right
to make it right and your brain
is going to do everything it can to
protect you from that ever happening
again
right and so it's going to create all
universes for you that you live in and
can navigate
and it's going to really build a nice
big concrete bunker around what happened
and drop into the ocean
and only you know it's there except
everyone around you know
something's there they just don't have
any clue as to what it is
right yeah and so
at some point sooner rather than later
you're gonna have to choose wholeness
and connection over secrets
you know that right yeah sounds like
you're there
have you ever told this to anybody have
you ever met with a counselor or a
trauma psychologist have you ever worked
through
what actually happened um i tried to
meet with a counselor one time and i
don't know
i don't know if i just didn't click with
her or what
hey i'm gonna stop you right there okay
this is the third person you've told me
about that's not your abuser
and it's the third apology you've made
for your interaction with that person
and a hallmark of an abused person is
somebody who thinks
every relational inconsistency every
relational issue is their fault
they screwed something up if so if
nothing else you get from this phone
call is you hang up the phone
and for the rest of your life you stand
six inches taller you got me
yeah you're a strong brilliant beautiful
brave woman
period okay
okay so it may be that you didn't click
maybe the counselor sucked maybe this is
a big like if you haven't worked with
people who do
trauma they don't you know you take
special classes for this in grad school
right this isn't just part of the
curriculum
right um and it may be
that you don't want to burden your
parents
but it may be like they're the only ones
that can walk alongside you
maybe you don't want to burden your
husband that's what he signed up for
now this is big right he didn't know
these secrets are coming but he said for
better or worse
sickness and health right
so you went and saw a counselor it
what was her response
um i'm just shaking my head here because
i can feel it coming
she pretty much told me that i sounded
um
like i was over the situation and
um that i was
that i was fine like um
so one day you don't have any more video
games to play
just reach out to the whatever licensing
board is in that community or that state
and file on her or him
for being a terrible unethical counselor
because that person doesn't have the
right to see
any more people okay because that
person's gonna hurt other people
good great sounds like you're good man
shake it off all right high five
wow are you over it now
no i was being sarcastic
um i know clearly oh
man so here so here's what you've got
ahead of you
you've got a number of
um challenging sessions with a trauma
therapist
whether that's emdr whether that's
more adult centered trauma focused
cognitive behavioral therapy whatever
that looks like relational therapy
you've got some work to do here okay
and my promise is the theft of your life
won't come back those years that were
stolen from you
um the innocence that was taken from you
that won't
those will be there those happen but
what can happen
think of it this way you know those
bricks that are in your backpack now
that you carry into every relationship
every room and even when you're just
peacefully laying there on the couch
watching tv sometimes your heart will
just
spin up on you and you'll or you'll see
some guy in a mall who reminds you of
some way somebody looked at you
whatever the thing is i want you to know
those bricks that you're carrying around
that
that literally bend you over and and
lean you down like right they make you
crouch over because you're so exhausted
and every relationship you go into you
go in looking up at it right you're
going apologetically i'm so sorry i
didn't mean to i'm so old
it's probably me you can take those
bricks out
and you're going to stand six inches
taller and here's the beautiful part you
can redeem that stuff
the bricks become the
pathway that you walk on and equally as
important it becomes the path where your
kids walk on
your neighbors walk on making meaning of
this thing
grieving it and healing from it and i'm
telling you right now
you can heal you can't grieve it hard
and you can't heal
but you've got to have other people in
your life right
yeah so my recommendation
on this is yes you've got to tell your
husband does he know you're in
a really abusive relationship in the
past yes
okay to what extent
um
he knows that my ex was um
physically abusive as far as hitting me
um i have a
burn mark on my arm that he knows he
he did that um he knows that he raped me
[Music]
um so he knows this isn't like an evil
guy by the way is this guy in jail
oh yeah uh he's dead okay
that's that's another call liz um
yeah hey and here's another weird thing
that most people don't know
that probably messed you up didn't it it
did
yep people think that oh that guy who is
evil and hurt me is dead
hooray that's not how that works either
right there's a part of you that
is that's a whole other trauma right
yeah
so here's what you i'm not gonna say to
your husband
you do but that's not the point of this
call you owe this to you
i want you to sleep all night
and i want you to laugh from your guts
and i want you not to have to scan every
room for who's coming next for liz
and that's what healing looks like okay
i want you to be able to eat a whole
meal
i want you to be able to your husband to
say some freaky thing
and be like hey you want to try this in
the bed and and i don't want every alarm
you have to go off
i want you to be able to go all right
weirdo you know what i mean
i want you to be able to engage him in
that way and i know you do too
and so the healing starts
here's the thing you've told him more
than you think you have
right now you feel this big giant deep
dark secret and it is it's a big secret
right
and he's gonna be understandably
shaken to his core right yeah
he is going to be he's going to be
frustrated he's probably going to say
why didn't you tell me why'd you lie to
me
all that stuff is fair and
he already knows a big chunk of it
he knows that you've stared evil in the
eye he just doesn't know how far evil
dragged you
down the road right and so here's my
recommendation my recommendation is
you let him know
hey i'm gonna go do some hard trauma
work
i have to right
if you look at the aces a-c-e-s
it's a trauma scale one to ten my guess
is you are
really high on that asus score it's a
score out of ten you can get online and
take just uh
we'll link one to show notes you can get
online and get the ace of scores
and nadine burke harris dr harris out of
i think she's at san francisco
um really remarkable physician and
researcher
but it's really revolutionized trauma
response it's ten questions
it's simple and what i'll tell you is if
you have four
of the ten um your likelihood of
cancer and heart disease and stroke is
exponentially higher and then you go
five so we're not just talking about hey
i'm in a bad mood
talking about your body starts to
dissolve itself right
and then you get up to six seven eight
so here's what i'm telling you that
i want you to treat this like a medical
condition
you've got because it is you've got it
is a heart issue it's a
it's a soul issue but it's a medical
condition
i want you to let your husband know
hey i told you i was in an abusive
relationship a dark ugly messy one
there's more to it
that i've just got to work through and i
am not in a place where i can talk to
you about it i
promise i will and i promise you i'm
gonna do i'm gonna do the hard work to
heal
and at some point y'all will be in
couples therapy together too as y'all
walk through this
but this is a big enough deal that i
want you to have some healing
and strategies under your belt
some breathing techniques some
relational techniques some connection
techniques
before you lay this out and i think it
would be healthy to have
a another counselor another person in
the room with you whether it's a
therapist a psychologist or the like
i have been in these rooms when a wife
finally tells a husband something
nothing this this serious this this this
um traumatic but some pretty tough stuff
and it's just good to have other people
in the room um
it adds a l it adds a
right um and there's just a level of
safety in that room
okay so the the truth telling starts
today the truth telling starts this
weekend
with hey you know how evil this was
it's worse all right there's stuff i'm
coming to terms with that i was a part
of that i got dragged through
that i'm still messing with and i've got
to go see somebody i got a budget for
this this is going to be a part of your
life for a season
and i want you to find a good trauma
counselor in your area
okay and be very specific about that
what a lot of trauma victims like your
experience especially sex trafficking um
sexual abuse they become very very
strong
and very very good at being who
what they need to be to be safe in a
certain situation because you've been in
a lot of unsafe situations fair
yes yeah so your your superpower
is contortionism right um
psychological you can become whatever
you need to be to be safe in a situation
do whatever you gotta do to get out of
that room alive
right yeah
now the hard part is learning how to be
vulnerable again
and you're just gonna have to get
somebody to walk alongside you
do you promise you'll do that for liz
yes
okay you're at a point where you can't
do this by yourself
and fast forward a year fast forward six
months
you go do some really hard trauma work
some scary
but with a great professional some good
trauma healing
you learn some skills how to take back
control of your body
right and then fast forward to your
husband's in this room and you all have
this conversation
and you've got a therapist that you
trust in there or two
i've been a part of one there was two of
us in there um
and you have this conversation with your
husband in your heart of hearts
what's he gonna do
hug me and cry exactly right
i think he's gonna hug you until you
can't heart so you gotta say hey
like i gotta breathe right
yeah sounds like a guy that loves you to
the moon and back
he fell for your stupid hey i thought
you asked for my number line for crying
out loud
right
sounds like you won the lottery with
this guy i want you to love liz as much
as he does
okay okay and i want you to recognize
you're gonna have to learn
new skills to do that you're a brave
woman thanks for being vulnerable with a
million strangers that you don't know
and walking people through man
reminds me of this old
reminds me of this old um
quote it's attributed to 50 different
people but
be nice to everybody because
behind smiles and behind their eye
crinkles everyone's fighting battles
that you have
no idea they're in war right
i know i butchered that quote but and
you don't know
if the person next to you who had a
rough boyfriend once
you don't know the depths of hell that
she may have traveled
thanks for being brave liz so grateful
you escaped i'm so grateful
that you had people along the way the
hotel owner the people who said
you're safe here pets are safe here
so glad you met a guy who loves you for
who you are so glad you've been brave to
talk to him about your abuse thus far
and you're going to take the next step
and begin a healing journey
good for you good for you good for you
and by the way
if you are married to somebody if you've
been dating somebody who's experienced
deep deep trauma
if they ever have the courage to come
tell you what's going on what happened
man um
the first response is always i love you
and a hug and that's about it questions
come later
discussions come later uh how come
that's all later
the best thing to say in that moment is
nothing
but weep with them sit with them hug
them if that's safe
and don't let go thank you so much for
your call liz
hey you know what i'm gonna wrap up
today's show um
so i asked
i don't even know where it is
i think i threw it on the floor
i thought i had it what did i do with it
ah here it is
to wrap up today's show
i asked ben the fill-in producer hey
grab me some lyrics to a song
and i did and he did there's a little
known secret here
at ramsay solutions i think the worst
band in the history of
music is smashing pumpkins for a hundred
reasons
and what band did ben pull up well
played ben
i see what you did here
you know what i'm gonna use your
smashing pumpkin lyrics i'm gonna go
with the ones i had
how do you like them apples oh off the
cherry pie record back in the 90s or
something
warrant really came through for me
the song called i saw red and it goes
like this
oh it must be magic how inside your eyes
i see my destiny
every time we kiss i feel you breathe
your love so deep inside of me
and if the moon and stars should fall
they'd be easy to replace i would lift
you up to heaven
and you would take their place plot
twist
but when i saw red oh then i saw red
when i opened up the door i saw red my
heart just spilled onto the floor
and i didn't need to see his face i saw
yours
i saw red and then i closed the door
one of the greatest lines in 90s middle
i don't think i'm going to love you
anymore
way to go janie lane in warren this has
been the dr john dolone show
[Music]
you